reflects on how you have to come and
deal with that mess so do you are you're
you're basically saying that the girl
with less bodies still has trauma is
that your problem yes yeah yeah but
we're talking about like a balance of
probabilities so if a girl's been with
50 dudes versus five dudes who's who's
more likely going to have more trauma
yeah just the balance of probabilities
and you know i mean i've always said i
like
rollo tomasi has a quote where it's like
it's not the number it's the number of
like guys that she saw alpha as alpha so
it's like the number of
men that she's comparing you to but the
bigger the number is the more it's just
a balance of probabilities but when like
when you were talking earlier about
dating and sex like
if sex is just a physical act you can
sleep with a guy that you're not dating
and
that whether that be a one night stand
or just a fling
like why does that necessarily need to
affect you in that way that it puts you
through trauma it doesn't you can do
that yeah like that's totally fine but
men don't want to deal with that
that's like i mean they don't do it
anyway i mean they don't deal with it
for some people
plus you have to remember that again the
characteristics of a woman that
frees it up to that capacity is going to
have other implications in that
relationship
and again why would you as a man want to
take that risk
what kind of implications are we talking
about here so if we're talking about
like promiscuity and the effect it can
have on a relationship
if that man isn't ticking all the
biological works boxes whereas he
probably would be would have been before
if the woman was less promiscuous the
likelihood is that she's more likely to
stay we caught the statistic before that
70 to 80 of women leave their men it's
not men leaving it's women leaving so if
men are out here having more sex and
women are having more sex but as a
consequence of us both having more sex
you're less likely to stay with me then
what you're doing is causing a problem
to you successful relationships so
you're actively breaking up nuclear
homes because you can't maintain your
your discipline then women aren't
leaving because of sex even because of
financial reasons that we said so it's
not about i don't i think it's
sexualization
did you know one of the number one
indicators of divorce is the woman out
earning the man
i can see that yeah
but it goes back to because the woman
one of the reasons is because the woman
is around all these men that she wants
but i know but then if if we're talking
about is it is it sex or is it money
because if it's if she's leaving because
he's not earned enough that's different
than this no that's selfish but that's
it's about being a selfish woman that is
selfish if you're leaving and breaking
up a home because he's not earning
enough money that's selfish
so it's okay to want that but if you
sign the papers if you got married to
him and now you think you're above him
because you make more i remember quite
sure remember we're talking about
characteristics here so yeah with the
characteristics of a woman that wants to
free up for everybody when she is around
men that she wants she's going to act in
those
those feelings whereas a woman who's
more disciplined is able to say no to
things
because she's had less
she's more likely to sex
and they say that 20 of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs that's why they
don't want a promiscuous woman they're
afraid they're going to pass their
resources on to the wrong um
onto a kid that's not theirs well
unknowing or knowing nothing i'm not
knowing so how do they get the
statistics don't know it's dna tests so
when they come together when they find
out i just want to know how that was how
that was possible we literally spoke to
a lady yesterday that said that the guy
was the kid was 11 years old before he
found out the woman just came clean
because her conscience couldn't take it
no more mad this is what men have to go
through do you think they
do you think the women
stay or do you think they settle because
it's like
if they've been exposed to airbnc men
one toxic one really nice they know how
then to spot a really nice guy and a
toxic one whereas like if they've had
maybe one boyfriend and that's the only
toxic one they've had that's the only
familiarity they've had with a partner
do you know i mean so sometimes having
say a promiscuous girl they have that
knowledge now you see where you go ahead
like men do because you're saying like
men can spread their seeds so they know
what they want logically logically that
makes sense yeah then we have the data
to prove that that doesn't work so what
you're saying would be make sense in the
ideal world but ideally that doesn't
actually happen i mean why do you think
why do you think fathers were so
involved in the vetting process for
women we don't make good decisions in
men on our own
no i don't know
like that's why half of women over 30
are single and childless because the
average age of first marriage is 27 to
28 in the u.s and in the uk it's 31. so
clearly how involved is your dad going
to be in the vetting process for a
husband if you're 31. saying that as
well look at the
the idea when people say oh she has
daddy issues
because without without a masculine
presence to guide you you're bound to
make background father presence remember
mexicans not all fathers are masculine
yeah for a father a masculine father a
masculine presence that that is able to
tell
right from wrong when it comes to men
what about beethoven
i'm just saying because not all men
not all men alpha so
i think having
alpha back then i think having a father
figure for example my my my godfather
that brought me up
he wasn't what what macho man
he he provided he was actually doesn't
mean much or mandatory i know but but we
said earlier that's what kind of what
people go to dependable did they say
much of okay masculine so masking for me
is a macho i don't see it because
that might be a problem
let me let me tell you what i think of
when i think of masculine just from like
a woman's point of view it's a guy that
doesn't put up with women's [ __ ] so when
i think of a beta guy i think of a guy
that just bends over and does whatever
the girl wants
and she's he's just will do anything to
make her happy but not in a good way
like he's a kiss-ass and when i think of
a masculine man i think of a guy that is
not afraid to say no and put his foot
down and he enjoys being the leader in a
relationship
because we don't we don't like men that
we can walk all over correct yeah yeah
like like the nice guys they're not
actually nice they're just trying to buy
your attention
with with things instead of just being a
masculine man
yeah i don't know because like my my
godfather for example
he like he would lead but
my grandmother would choose what he's
gonna wear when they go out
to some men that's like no what are you
doing but he's like whatever different
diamonds doesn't take anything for me to
put on the clothes she chose out for me
in the wardrobe but i realized that now
that maxine is not always a beater man
or he's not a masculine man but he
definitely run he ran the household but
so does she so maybe i've seen different
dynamics happening men and women have
different roles in households i mean i
mean some masculine men they're not
afraid to dish out responsibilities to
women that they're good at
like my my parents ran a business
together and my mom is very organized my
dad isn't she did a lot of the
organization type stuff right and like
the finances but at the end of the day
he's dishing out the responsibilities
she's not
he's the one he's the one saying what's
happening if there's a big move he's the
one making the decision she's not
and that's part of we talk about
submission at times for her opinion
in making those decisions before making
the oh yeah i mean of course he's gonna
but but she had to earn that he didn't
he he didn't just off the bat give her
the
ask for her opinion all the time
how did she earn it loyalty and showing
that she's competent and giving him
peace i imagine as well yeah
i mean because my mom um
my mom and dad went to different
colleges and basically my mom told or my
dad told my mom you can either move to
me or find a different boyfriend and she
moved to him quit and then she ended up
getting a teaching degree she quit her
teaching job to work for my dad and
helped him build a multi-million dollar
business they had 10 kids
but you know in modern day they would
say you know don't take that risk for a
man it's only going to end up don't quit
your job for a man it's only going to
end poorly my dad would say a similar
thing my dad would say to my mom or he
said and tell us is that i would see the
bigger picture while she sees all the
finer details so everybody has their
role to play within the system
as well behind it like there's a lot of
i am was with like a lot of um filipino
people from like the older generation
and in their
like culture at least back in their day
was
get for the women as well get an
education first if you used to get
married before an education the family
would disown you because it's like
one snap of a divorce and you've got
nothing and you've left us in the
filipino culture
really that's interesting it wasn't so
much about it i i don't know about like
all
around that continent of asia but at
least there they said to me
education always comes first and then
when you have that education backed up
then you would go pursue maybe a
relationship or whatever because if you
left especially of a woman changing your
last name there's nothing there holding
you as much towards them so it really
does depend on the culture without
interest the presence with people i
don't know if you want to get a
statistic
yeah the reason what i was looking up is
um i when i want to see how westernized
the country is i look at the average age
of first marriage in a country so one
country i didn't realize was so
westernized is ireland um the average
age of first marriage there is like 34
and 35.
because the more traditional it is they
they get married younger typically is
what i what i've seen this is just
anecdotal but the in the philippines is
27 and 29. so i guess they're
westernized too are they now yeah well
at least the people i speak were much
older so i don't know if it was just
because older times like you said your
parents would have said something
different because maybe in their times
it was different but i know now
it's probably more westernized a lot of
culture is now though isn't it like even
like the eastern south florida and yeah
it's messing [ __ ] up
i think with the point that you were
making with the example you gave about
your mum and dad and their working
relationship i think that works well
because your dad did not
um that's what arcs did he ask for her
opinion before making i think a lot of
men take this um
this title of leadership and run with it
to the point where you almost forget
that you have a woman there who's who's
almost meant to to help you essentially
what are the examples of that
well
where do you see that a lot of time the
men that that take the title of
leadership
and
uh use it to the point where in any in
everything in everything they they think
okay i'm the leader i'm gonna make all
the decisions without asking for your
opinion without but essentially that's
your part that's a dictatorship yeah
yeah yeah yeah essentially that's a but
that's that's what i'm trying to say so
it's a thing where if you are going to
to demand that to ask for
um oh the title of being of being the
leader you have to know what it actually
entails and i feel like a lot of a lot
of people don't know how to do that so
with a lot of these things a lot a lot
of what we are discussing is all well
and good but with if it's not taught to
the younger generation they're growing
up they're going to grow up with with
misconceptions about the realities of
life well i think most masculine men
that i talk to are okay with asking for
a woman's opinion like because on on
youtube i meet a lot of guys that make
it like stupid amounts of money like
more money than i'll ever make but i
know more about youtube than them and
i've had a lot of them ask me for advice
on youtube i think they just know like
they understand that men and women have
different roles
and i just want to say also you have to
remember as well that just being born a
man doesn't give you the entitlement of
leadership yeah
as she said yeah you have to earn the
sanctions you have to show the qualities
of of what a leader has before you can
have the title leadership so like
you and a lot of men watch kevin samuels
and think oh yeah whatever he says is
right and i'm you need to submit to me
no these things have to be earned unless
you prove yourself as worthy of these
things you're not entitled to them so
let's make that clear you know what's
funny so i i said i i like to run a lot
of my decisions through men so uh my
like i talked to my dad i get a lot of
advice for for things on my channel and
just like business decisions i also have
a manager that's a guy and i run a lot
of my decisions through him and so um i
always say that i like to run decisions
through men because they are they're
better at making decisions than they
think more long term and i just think
that's an
um an advantage that men have right not
all men but there's one guy who sent me
an email that just was like the subject
was a man to make your decisions and he
was basically propositioning like making
my decisions for me because he was a guy
do you think though
i was like the audacity yeah
he's a fool i know i was like which one
of you did that
like i didn't need any man i meant like
a competent one yeah yeah
do you think they're like a man just as
seen more as a leader role whereas like
if a woman wanted to be like head of
anything it seemed more as a challenge
because i feel like it is in a certain
way like a man could go for a spot and
it's
more respected upon where it's like say
like a woman is a head of anything
it's very like foreign still to us which
is kind of sad no i mean i think it's an
advantage oh my gosh
yeah every time i've worked in corporate
america they're trying to move me up
because they they have quotas they have
specific quotas where they need a
certain amount of women working i've
always worked in like male dominated
industries i think that's one of the
reasons my channel took off yeah it's
because i'm one of the few women that
talks about this stuff like i think
being a woman is an advantage in
business i've never felt disadvantaged
in any way in the world a few years ago
i can't remember what year it was but
then i think they changed the tax system
and then a bunch of companies made
women's ceos
literally just obviously when positions
became open you just see it out because
this these when i was still working in
finance i was on linkedin every day this
new ceo is women that knew ceo and that
new ceo's woman so that she said
it's actually very advantageous
in this day and age it's an advantage to
be a woman seeking out leadership roles
or seeking those niche especially highly
specialized skilled roles because they
did they want you in tech they want you
in engineering they want to make the
company look good it's branding is a lot
of different things but they want you
there so now is the best opportunity for
women to get into these high paid roles
i'll be honest i used to get in a lot of
trouble with my mum because i used to
say that
i think men
again
no